i
[Música]
los presidentes de china xi jinping y
rusia vladimir putin acordaron aumentar
su coordinación para afrontar las
supuestas amenazas a la seguridad
regional el encuentro se dio en el marco
de la inauguración de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno y en medio de la
tensión entre occidente y moscú
involucran ya
precisamente el presidente francés
emmanuel macon viajará hasta rusia y
ucrania para buscar una solución a la
escalada desatada por el despliegue de
tropas rusas en la frontera ucraniana
se cumplen 30 años desde el fallido
golpe de estado encabezado por hugo
chávez en venezuela un fracaso militar
pero el éxito político que le permitió
llegar al palacio de miraflores siete
años después por vía democrática
analizamos en esta emisión
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez damos inicio
en la capital china en el marco de la
inauguración de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno el presidente jean ping se
reunió con su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin y acordaron que enfrentarán juntos
las que calificaron de injerencias
externas en medio de las tensiones que
vive europa ante una invasión de rusia a
ucrania
en cuanto a nuestras relaciones
bilaterales se están desarrollando en
línea con el espíritu de amistad y
asociación estratégica y han alcanzado
un nivel sin precedentes
son un ejemplo de relaciones íntegras
que ayudan a ambas partes a
desarrollarse y apoyarse mutuamente al
mismo tiempo
uralde los juegos olímpicos de invierno
es el comienzo de la primavera y en este
día especial nos reunimos creo que esta
nueva reunión de primavera inyectará más
vitalidad a las relaciones entre china y
rúsia
tomando trivia y los juegos olímpicos de
invierno comenzaron en medio del boicot
internacional y de las protestas por
parte de activistas que acusan al
gobierno de beijing de violar los
derechos humanos andrés granadillo nos
amplía
fuegos artificiales dieron inicio a la
ceremonia inaugural de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en medio de la
burbuja que busca contener el avance de
la pandemia en el icónico estadio nido
de pájaro se reunieron tres mil atletas
de 91 países de los cuales 10 son
latinoamericanos a la ceremonia
asistieron además unos 25 líderes
extranjeros las competencias comienzan
en medio del boicot diplomático liderado
por eeuu y al que se sumó canadá reino
unido de australia el rechazo a las
denuncias de violaciones de derechos
humanos en china
[Música]
el rechazo se evidenció también en las
calles de diferentes países este grupo
de la minoría musulmana uigur denuncia
desde el exilio de los abusos a los que
son víctimas en china
persona esperamos que aquellos que
participan en los juegos olímpicos' que
respetan los derechos humanos y las
libertades levanten sus voces contra
esto
[Música]
porque es un crimen no sólo contra los
musulmanes y los uigures que viven allí
sino contra toda la humanidad
information and future simpatizante de
la organización iniciativa del tibet que
apoyan la autodeterminación y protección
de los derechos en la región sentaron
también su voz de protesta
el espíritu olímpico y los valores
olímpicos ya no se respetan en absoluto
esa es también la razón por la que
estamos parados aquí protestando y
tratando de crear conciencia de que la
idea de separar los deportes y la
política en los juegos olímpicos no se
ha practicado durante mucho tiempo la
nación sigue el ipswich los olímpicos de
invierno en beijing no son los primeros
en sufrir un boicot
primero se produjo en 1956 en melbourne
en medio de la polémica el gobierno
chino espera que tras prender el
pebetero todas las críticas se sin que
al margen de este boicot diplomático las
tensiones también se viven entre
occidente y rusia con esfuerzos
diplomáticos sin descanso para intentar
detener un eventual conflicto armado en
la frontera ucraniana en este sentido el
presidente francés emmanuel macon
visitará a rusia el lunes y ucrania el
martes mientras que la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
dijo que podría utilizar el gasoducto
nord stream 2 que conecta rusia con
alemania para sancionar al kremlin en
caso de que invadiera ucrania a la par
eeuu asegura tener pruebas de un
supuesto plan de moscú para justificar
una invasión
vamos ahora venezuela donde se cumplen
30 años desde el fallido golpe del
estado encabezado por hugo chávez el 4
de febrero de 1992 escuchamos sus
palabras cuando fue cuestionado al
respecto al salir de prisión
porque cuando nosotros que somos
soldados formados para la democracia
somos soldados humanistas decidimos hace
ya más de cinco años lanzar una rebelión
armada
nunca jamás llegamos a pensar ni
pensaremos instalar en venezuela una
dictadura militar lo cual sería dar un
salto atrás lo cual sería bueno devolver
las manillas del reloj nosotros cuando
nos alzamos en armas más de diez mil
soldados republicanos hace ya más de
cinco años en venezuela lo hicimos
contra un gobierno que no hay que
olvidar que traicionó un país y que ya
había utilizado a las fuerzas armadas
venezolanas para masacrar a un pueblo
para analizar esta información
conectamos con carmen beatriz fernández
ella es consultora política en data
estrategia y profesora de la universidad
de navarra bienvenido a france 24 a 30
años cual se puede considerar el
principal legado de este golpe de estado
si las causas que defendía chávez
parecen ser las mismas que dejan a la
nación suramericana como la destrucción
de la economía
la destrucción de la economía y la
destrucción de la democracia
hoy hoy 4 efe a 30 años de ese punto de
inflexión en el que el destino de
venezuela se torció hacia el abismo
porque en ese momento chávez afirmaba
estarle dando un golpe de estado a
carlos andrés pérez que era el
presidente demócrata en funciones pero
en realidad le estaba propinando un
golpe de estado a la democracia
venezolana eso la propia sociedad tardó
un tiempo en darse cuenta de ello pero
pero ese es ese golpe y arremetía contra
la democracia no solamente contra los
mandatarios
bueno hablemos más de ese panorama que
vivió venezuela hace 30 años porque el
entonces comandante chávez decide dar el
golpe de estado y qué fue lo que falló
pero
chávez
llega a donde llega por un 'mea culpa'
ss 4 de febrero que la sociedad valora
como algo
un gesto hidalgo que aceptaba el fracaso
en una operación militar muy distinto
por cierto a lo que hizo luego ya seis
años después una vez del gobierno que
todo fue más bien evadir culpas pero la
en aquel momento la sociedad y ciertas
élites no solamente justificaron el
golpe sino que en alguna medida
glorificaron a los golpistas la sociedad
en ese momento la sociedad venezolana
asumía la democracia como una condición
base a la que tenía pleno derecho y la
realidad se encargó de demostrar que
nunca se puede dar a la democracia por
descontado que la democracia necesita
mucho mimo
y está en continuo
transformación y en continuo
el enriquecimiento las condiciones bueno
hay que paso con chávez tras aceptar su
responsabilidad cuál fue la imagen que
quedó entre los venezolanos
si efectivamente
como ustedes lo han dicho
chávez fue mucho mejor político de
militar que militar fracasó en se vuelve
militar pero triunfó el golpe político
[Música]
en aquel momento también en ese año y
curiosamente hubo un libro muy potente y
unas ideas muy potentes las de william
en ese libro que se llamó el fin de la
historia del último hombre según la cual
el mundo estaba evolucionando hacia o en
una dirección donde el último hombre era
demócrata y capitalista chávez en ese
año se había demostrado que no era ni
democracia ni ni capitalista y no era
solamente un lugar dentro de esa
tendencia general sino que fue precursor
de algo que se convertiría después en
una tendencia creciente que esos rasgos
del populismo autoritario que
aparecieron primeramente en chaves pero
que luego se han encargado de ir
apareciendo en otras partes del mundo en
esta era que vivimos hoy que es la era
de una recesión
democrática global creo que
1992 también fue un punto de inflexión
en ese particular y un cierto impacto
global bueno y con la situación actual
con lo que está pasando y con lo que ha
pasado en los últimos años posible que
se produzca un nuevo golpe de estado en
venezuela
con las condiciones objetivas que
existían en ese entonces eran mucho
mejores a las a las que existen hoy no
lo que pasa es que si en venezuela no se
ha producido aún un golpe de estado es
porque se trata de un régimen militar o
sea se trata de unos militares que están
sosteniendo al régimen de nicolás maduro
esa esa es la realidad
por eso no no no
no es no son claras las posibilidades de
un golpe estaba un indicador clarísimo y
que quizás en el mar en dos ejes del
producto migratorio neto en el peor de
los muchos indicadores de estos 30 años
señora fernández a usted muchas gracias
por su análisis y a ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que
volvemos en breve aquí en france 24
[Música]